Dark Souls 3 is tough but not if you're
the Magic Man with three different
powerful magic attacks and ash Estus
flasks for days
you're an Opie magic beast the Academy
assassin came with three spells in the
Dark Souls 3 Network stress test the
souls art is a superfast damage healer
that can be changed together it can be
combined with a physical attack to
finish the job
the only major issue is the lock on
reach doesn't go very far and if I'm not
locked on my magic is pretty much
worthless soul arrow is a bit slower but
with time comes more power I combined it
with l2 which is a timed damage boost to
take on more powerful knights in
forehead but I had to be quick because
the boost lasts about five seconds
both of these not only take Nana but a
good chunk of stamina so I had to move
around to not get hit and something I've
never seen before was just soul great
sort it looks like them
hot damn I did this during the Dark
Souls Network stress test so there's a
good chance a lot of this isn't final
they'll probably be tweaking a lot of
things currently though just a hint of
magic and your powerful wizard that
can't be stopped
will be keeping you up to date with the
latest on Dark Souls 3 so stay tuned to
games 5